[MUSIC PLAYING]
TANIA KATAN: Thank you.
Thank you, Natasha.
NATASHA: I have a cape for you.
TANIA KATAN: I mean,
that's the stance you take
when you're getting a cape.
I don't want to be rude.
Thank you.
And I want you to
know-- thanks to Natasha
and, also, I typically
wear my cape on the inside.
So, if you don't have
a cape on the outside,
you can keep it on the inside.
Am I amplified and
ready to rock and roll?
Yeah.
OK, so, what we're
going to do today
is we're going to test the
limits of what is probable,
what is profitable,
and what is possible
when we bring our imagination
to the workspace--
when we bring our
imagination to our homes,
when we bring our imagination
to the streets, when
we bring our imagination
to a Talks at Google.
What?
So, instead of starting
at the beginning,
we're going to
start at the ending.
So, please stand up.
OK.
On the count of
three, you are going
to give yourselves
and each other
the best standing
ovation you have in you.
One, two, three.
[CHEERING]
Yeah!
Woo!
OK.
OK, OK.
You can sit down physically,
but stay standing emotionally
for the whole time.
So, I want you to
remember that all of us
here have and will dare
to share our wildest ideas
and will be a little scared.
Or we will deign to raise our
hands at an all hands meeting
and share an idea
that scares us.
Or, we might be taking the
stage and giving a presentation
and we're a little freaked out.
And so, you can
remember this moment
when we all gave each other and
ourselves a standing ovation,
and you can take that with you.
OK?
So, I have spent
the last 10 years
consciously bringing
creativity into the work
space and imagination.
And I'm talking about
when I've worked
and before that a little
less consciously--
I hadn't really developed this
idea of creative trespassing.
But when I was
bagging groceries,
when I worked at
it as a barista,
when I worked in a museum,
when I worked in technology.
And, as I got more conscious
about this infusing imagination
and creativity, I started
to notice two things that
were really astounding to me.
And the first
thing is is that we
don't need to work in
a job or a field that
is uniquely creative
in order to be uniquely
creative within our work.
And the second
thing that I learned
is that if we bring
imagination to confront
our self-limiting beliefs,
obstacles, everyday challenges,
that we will experience
unlimited solutions, ideas,
and innovations.
True story, news at 10.
I'm done.
And that's what
compelled me to write
this book "Creative
Trespassing," which
I'll show you--
oh, my gosh, it's so red
and white and fantastic.
OK, and so, what I
want to my talk today
is really about some
moments or stories
where I learned to see my
self-limits as opportunities
to creatively trespass-- to
maybe add something that wasn't
there and enliven not just
myself, but colleagues
and the mission and
vision of the companies
that I worked for.
So, anybody here go to
contemporary art museums?
OK, about 50%.
And somebody is like, meh,
only if it's free day.
That's fine.
I sort of felt like, meh,
when somebody offered me
a job in a contemporary
art museum.
I'm like, I don't
understand the rules.
They're always saying
like, don't touch things.
And then it's contemporary art
so they're like, why aren't you
touching it?
Very confusing.
And they wanted somebody, like
a rule-breaker from the outside
to come inside and
create wild programs
and generate new revenue streams
and increase attendance--
pretty regular metrics
for functioning, right?
And so, I got there
and I started--
I did what I do in theater,
that's my background.
You sort of assess
the situation.
You're like, who's my audience,
what do I have to work with,
what are the props?
And I realized there
was this weird thing
I've never heard of called
Employee of the Month.
Anybody familiar with it?
I'm like, Employee of the Month?
That sounds fantastic.
How do I win that?
And you're laughing-- again,
HR was like, Tania, you
don't win it, you earn it.
And I was like, then I will
earn your vote and win it.
And here's what happened--
I'll show you.
So, the program I created was
called "Out of the Cubicle,"
because I was like--
they brought me into to
think outside the box,
they stuffed me in a cubicle--
ironic or scary,
it's a fine line.
And I decided to create a
programmatic area online
where people could see that
those of us who thought museums
are kind of sterile and the
rules, I don't understand,
and am I OK to go in?
Will I fit in?
I created this program where
I ran around the offices
and actually got to
know my colleagues
and made these videos that
expose the fact that art
museums, just like any
other office culture,
are unique and
boring and exciting
and everything in between.
And so, people started
watching this program--
they came in through the United
States, than other countries.
And so, I was doing
my job, essentially.
But here's the critique
that people had--
and this was a corporately
structured museum.
There were probably
200 employees
and there were lots of rules.
And I said, working and fun,
they're not mutually exclusive.
And then I showed
them why they're not.
So, I did lunch
programs in the museum--
that was part of my job.
I increased revenue streams.
So, not only did people
come in through the videos,
but they literally wanted
to come and see what
was happening in the museum.
I also created a program
called Arm Wrestling for Art--
crazy.
Where I used my teeny
tiny, nonprofit budget
to buy an arm wrestling table--
because that makes sense.
And then, we put it in
the middle of the museum--
because the problem I
was trying to solve was,
who here likes art?
Who here can afford to buy
the art that they really like?
All the hands go down.
And I thought, how
do we democratize
the acquiring of art?
How do we make art
accessible for everyone?
What do museums not do?
They don't give away art.
And so I thought, let's
make people sweat it out
and arm wrestle
for a piece of art.
That seems fair.
That's how we'd
solve the problem
as kids, that's how we're
going to do it as adults.
So, we increased
attendance numbers.
That's my job.
Brand awareness--
everybody started
to know about Scottsdale
Museum of Contemporary Art.
It's a small
contemporary art museum,
but it had all of this
new life and people
coming through the doors
and through the videos.
Earned media, which anybody in
marketing knows, you pay a lot
and then you're like, oh
that didn't have an impact.
We didn't go viral.
So, we just earn it
the old fashioned way.
And then you drop the mic.
So, once upon a time, I was
giving a talk at a startup
week, and these two engineers
from American Express
came up to me after my talk.
They're all like, oh, my god,
that was so cool-- creativity,
blah blah blah.
And they're like, we want
to start an innovation
lab in our company, but we
have no buy-in from our boss,
no money, no space, and nobody
thinks it's a good idea.
What's your solve, Tania?
Oh, my gosh.
I'm like-- totally easy.
I'm going to introduce you to
an artist named Meg Dogood.
So, Meg lives in Chicago.
She had a dream.
Her dream was to have four
walls, a gallery space.
That's it.
She wanted four walls to be
able to put people's artwork
in from around the world.
She had no money.
She was like a
full-time artist--
no patrons, no space, no buy-in,
no American Express card,
I'm certain.
And here's what she did
to solve that problem--
she didn't have
the limiting belief
that the guys at
American Express had.
So, she created Clutch Gallery.
It's a 25 square inch space
in the heart of her purse.
It's totally absurd
and wackily wonderful.
And so, she solved a problem.
And I'll show you one
of her installations--
it's a painting show.
And so, it just goes to
show you that had she
had the same limiting belief--
like I don't have money.
I don't have space.
I don't have buy-in.
She never would have created
this innovative space.
And artists love the challenge
of trying to create artwork
for 25 by 25 square inches.
I know.
OK.
So, who here went
to first grade?
Great.
I knew we'd have
something in common.
So, I went to first grade.
I was five years old, which
was younger than the kids--
not because I was real
smart, but because my parents
had sex at a certain
period of time
and I was born in September.
So there was no
like, she's so smart.
So, I was younger than the
other kids and I was like--
I was super chubby, but it
was all focused in my belly.
So it was like I
had a gut, you know?
And I wore eyeglasses.
Anybody wear eyeglasses as a
four or five, six-year-old?
Fantastic.
We thought we were really cool.
My mom said, you're cute, Tania.
I felt sophisticated
and more intellectual
than my counterparts.
I was ready to rock.
So, I get on the school bus for
the first day of first grade
and I'm like, I'm
looking good, what?
I've got my glasses, and
I'm just rock and roll.
Like oh.
But, there didn't seem to
be any early adopters of me.
That's fine.
And so, I get on the bus and I
see a girl who's about my age--
and the bus is
about to take off--
so I slide into one of
those pleather benches
and sit next to her.
And I'm like, let the day begin.
And she looks me square
in the eye and I'm like--
I like this assertiveness.
And she's like, four eyes.
I know.
So, every single day of
the first week of school
I get on the bus and I try
to avoid the child tyrant.
I'd find a seat over here.
And somehow, that little menace
managed to sneak in and call me
four eyes.
And I was like sad and lonely
and didn't know what to do.
So, I consulted my mom.
And my mom was like Tania,
four eyes are better than two.
And I'm like, not only does
that little girl suck at math,
but she sucks at life.
And so I was like,
great, I'm armed
and I'm ready to rock and roll.
And so I get on the bus
with my newfound phrase
and I sit next to
her on purpose.
And she's like, four
eyes, and I'm like,
four eyes are better than two.
And she said, no, they're not.
And I said nothing.
I had no comeback at all.
The good news is that I grew up.
And, oh, somebody--
I was talking
about this story the other
day and somebody was like,
what happened to
this little girl?
And I'm like, well, you know she
didn't invent Google Glass, OK?
She's not a co-founder
of Warby Parker.
But what I've learned over
years of being in the world
is that little critic is not
only on the outside of us,
but a lot of times we have
that little child tyrant
on the inside of us.
And also what I've learned is
that when we see her or him
or non-gender binary person and
we acknowledge and we say, OK,
I see you, and we let go--
that's super helpful.
And I learned
another thing too--
that nobody writes
books or plays
or makes software for or
about anybody who's perfect.
You wouldn't want to
read a book if everybody
fit in and was perfect.
To be perfect or to fit
in is to be invisible.
And I just didn't
want to be invisible.
So, that was a really good
moment for me to learn.
That's me.
Stop it right now.
Is my mom here?
And, clearly, I was going to
audition for the Village People
the next day.
Oh, my gosh.
OK.
So, at some point
in my career, I
received a phone call from a
software company named AxoSoft.
And they were like, Tania,
we've seen you performing
and presenting around
town, we'd like
to talk to you about software.
And I'm like software?
That sounds awesome.
I don't know what
they're talking about.
I love cashmere.
And so, I took a leap of faith.
I really do.
But I can't afford it, so
I go to second-hand stores
and purchase it.
Thank you.
So, I took a leap of
faith and I decided
to meet with this
software company.
And I met with the CEO at
the time, Lawdan Shojaee.
She's like, we really
like your energy.
That's why we brought you in.
And I'm like, I like your
energy, that's why I came in.
She's like, but we're
not offering you a job.
And I'm like, OK, why am I here?
I don't understand.
And she's like,
we've always wanted
to have a brand evangelist.
You would make a
great evangelist.
And I was like,
that would totally
freak my Jewish mom out.
Yeah.
I want to be an evangelist.
Can I get a witness?
And so, I started work at
this company, and my first day
on the job I was like, what
is this magical software we're
selling?
Is it like a tool
for telling stories?
Is it a magical
paintbrush that allows
artists to make work on wall?
What is it?
And she was like, oh, it's a
B2B project management software
for software developers.
And I was like trapped
in slow motion,
like, what are you saying?
I don't understand that.
And soon, I learned I didn't
understand a lot of stuff.
You know, I would hear
people talking about AI
and I was like, oh, that's when
a British person is at a pub
and they ask for more beer.
They're like, I would
like another point.
That's not the case.
I also heard people
talking about-- they
were like, open source,
open source, open source--
and I'm like, don't
kiss that person.
I'm pretty sure that
that's no bueno.
So, I had a lot
of learning to do.
And, unfortunately--
and fortunately--
within the first two months
of being there and knowing
absolutely very
little about software,
my boss came to a
colleague and I and said,
we are going to host a
girls in technology event.
It's an inaugural one, and I
want to show up in a big way,
so come up with a big idea
around women in technology.
This is April 2015 just
to give some context
So, my colleague and I
Sara, we're brainstorming.
Came up with nothing.
Then I went for a
little walk and I
started thinking about
women in the tech space
and women in lots
of spaces and how,
a lot of times, we're not
seen, heard, or celebrated
for the superheroes we are.
And so, I came up
with this symbol--
I didn't come up with her, she's
been around for a long time.
The bathroom lady-- she's here.
She's made an appearance.
I've seen her twice today.
Thank you.
And I knew that this
symbol was immediately
recognizable across
cultures, across genders.
And I didn't know anything else.
I just had like--
it wasn't even an idea,
it was just a symbol.
And I brought the symbol back
to my colleague and I'm like,
here she is.
And my colleague's like, OK.
And that was sort of that.
But I couldn't shake
the fact that--
see the shape of her dress?
It's a triangle.
And I thought, gosh,
yeah, it's a dress,
and it looks kind of
like the shape of a cape.
And so I printed out the
vector and made a few lines
and then I'm like,
see it right there.
And AxoSoft-- we came
up with the campaign--
It Was Never a Dress.
And I will show you what
happened with it, because I
think it's important to play.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- When Tania and Sara came
to me and they gave me
their pitch on this
idea, I immediately
saw it and I thought, wow,
yes, I completely agree.
This was big.
- Initially, I thought of
a symbol that was easily
recognizable, and I thought
of the bathroom lady,
because she's everywhere--
just everywhere in the world.
That lady gets around.
So, I printed out an image of
the symbol, and I took a pencil
and started drawing some lines.
And, very quickly,
she had a cape on,
and she was fully present.
And it was as if she'd
been there this whole time
and I just hadn't seen her.
- We were at the conference.
So, we were pretty busy.
We were on social media.
We saw the first tweet and we
were like, wow, this is great.
Someone is really
connecting with the image.
And then "Huffington
Post" retweeted it.
That was kind of the
beginning of it going viral.
- And then, bam, in 24 American
hours, It just blew up.
I think people were very excited
to see that they weren't just
a symbol of the mundane,
but they're actually
a symbol of the extraordinary.
- We're trying to create
a community and a forum.
So, a woman was
telling us about how
she had shown that image to
her young son and daughter,
and then later they had
gone to the restroom
and the kids were excited and
they said, hey, mom, we're
going into the
superheroes bathroom.
I thought, that's how we measure
success is the next generation,
now they are seeing
things differently
and their perceptions
have been shifted.
- We started having an
overwhelming request
for merchandise.
However, we didn't
want to commoditize
the conversations that
were taking place on,
It Was Never a Dress.
So we thought, let's start a
Steam scholarship with ASU,
and we plan on fueling
that scholarship
with the merchandise.
Tania was brought into
AxoSoft as an evangelist,
and part of the things
that she's phenomenal with
is public speaking.
It's only natural for her to be
popping up maybe in your city
soon where she will be
speaking on this campaign
and helping keep
the movement going.
- It Was Never a Dress
campaign is really a story,
and it's also a proposition
for other people
to share their stories.
So, yes, I will be
going out into the world
and speaking publicly
about It Was Never a Dress.
You can invite me
to your hometown.
There's no crowd that's
too small or too large.
Because if we see
women differently,
we see the world differently.
If we see women differently,
[INAUDIBLE]
[CHEERING]
[CHANTING]
[END PLAYBACK]
TANIA KATAN: One
thing that was really
astounding about this moment
in terms of my work life
and my creative life
merging was my job--
I was embedded in marketing.
I was an evangelist.
My job was to learn the product
and to go out into the world
and preach the good word of B2B
project management software.
The end.
And, being presented
with this challenge,
solve a problem that you
really know very little about.
You've been a woman in
technology for two months,
do something.
And I really saw that
as an opportunity
to use some of the skills that
I had developed as a playwright
in theater school to see and
engage an audience with text,
with a story.
And I went above
and beyond my job,
because it was something
that was important to do.
And even though I no
longer work for AxoSoft,
we created this beautiful thing
that's bigger than all of us
together.
And something that I write
about in "Creative Trespassing"
that a lot of people forget
is that we have an opportunity
to leave a creative
legacy at our work.
We can leave people
and processes
in better shape than
when we arrived there.
It took me a long
time to learn that--
I mean, I definitely had
some jobs where I'm like,
you refill your own paper.
I was out.
Ink cartridge-- my
pie hole, you know?
And then I left.
And so, I'm really proud
of myself that I left.
And I think that that's
really important,
because as we sort
of conflate or we
remove the space
between work and life,
between fun and work,
that we actually
have all of these
opportunities to create.
So, I would like to do
something right now.
I feel like we started at
the ending, so let's end
at the beginning, right?
And, after this, I would love
to have a little Q&A slash
conversation.
That's Italian for conversation.
So, we're just going to take
a moment to close our eyes,
and I'm going to lead you
through a very short mind's eye
journey.
If you've not done a mind's
eye journey, all it means
is that I will gently guide
you, and you just receive.
That's it.
So, I want you to imagine one
of your self-limiting beliefs.
And, by that, I mean
a belief that you
hold that stops you from having
and experiencing more joy, more
creativity, and
pursuing your dreams.
So, it could be anything from,
I don't deserve a raise to,
I can't call myself an artist,
or I don't belong here.
So, see this
self-limiting belief.
I want you to gently let it go.
And when you feel like
you've let it go--
and this is a longer
process than just now--
but when you've
let it go for now,
I want you to open your eyes.
OK.
And now that you've
let something go,
there's room to take a leap.
So, we're going to stand up.
And this isn't a big,
performative gesture.
The most important part
about taking a leap
is that we're doing it together.
And so, it's-- bend your
knees just a little bit,
just slightly.
And, again, it's
not about jumping
highest, it's just about--
we didn't sign any waivers.
This is a gentle jump.
Again, the most important part
is that we do it together.
So, I'm going to count--
on the count of three,
we're going to gently take
a leap of faith together.
OK-- one, two, three.
Awesome.
Thank you so much.
I appreciate it.
And also, here's something I--
I've worked really
hard and focused
to feel comfortable in front
of human beings and presenting.
And even I get
nervous sometimes--
and I'm guessing that all
of us get nervous sometimes.
And you can remember
the beginning
if you need a standing ovation
from all of us and you.
And you can also
remember that when you're
leaping into the unknown--
when you're starting
a new job, when you're
tackling a new project, when
you're sharing your ideas,
that we're all leaping with you.
I think that's helpful to know.
I would love to engage in a
little questions and answers.
And, if you have no questions,
I'll ask you questions,
but I don't think you're
going to want that.
I'm kidding.
I'm totally kidding.
AUDIENCE: Oh, I was like,
oh, you're very intuitive.
How do you write a book?
TANIA KATAN: How do
you write a book?
This is actually something
that I write about
in "Creative Trespassing"--
whether you're
wanting to write a book
or make a career shift
or actually try on a
different role, you start.
And so, you write a
few lines about what
you think the book is about.
Maybe you write a
few lines about what
you want your next
job to look like
or what you want your
next project to look like.
And then you leave it
for a day, and then you
come back a day later.
And then you don't look at
it and you write some more.
So, this is how I've
written this book,
and this is how a lot of
authors that I know write
is they write a little a lot.
You know what I'm saying?
And if you're thinking about
or you already have a practice
of writing in a journal or
writing a book or whatever,
a lot of times we have this
self-limiting belief that we
put ourselves on a schedule
and if we do not adhere to that
schedule, we will just stop--
game over.
And I would suggest
to you that you--
even if you mess up
your own schedule
that only you gave you--
that you forgive
yourself and continue on.
So, do a little a lot.
And also, I find that
accountability-- for me,
personally, I like to have my
personal board of directors
that I'm like, you guys,
here's what I'm doing.
I will send you
some pages, I don't
need you to read
them, I just you
need to know they're coming.
Or I need you to read them
and I need some feedback,
I need to beta test these ideas.
Very keen of beta testing
lives and projects--
love it.
So, yeah.
That's a little a lot.
Yeah, thanks, Kate.
AUDIENCE: I was
curious about when
you were saying you were
getting criticism around,
oh, she's just running
around having fun.
And how you felt about that
whether you were just like--
blew it off because you have
all those checked boxes of I'm
so great, or did
that feel bad to you?
I'm curious what you felt.
TANIA KATAN: That's
a great question.
All of the above.
And I remember, actually,
when that news was delivered.
We were in an all-hands meeting
for just the museum staff.
And there were like
20 of us there,
and my boss sort of
delivered the news--
like there are people who
are really concerned who
find you problematic.
And he's like, and I want
you to know, I got your back.
And then I made a
realization-- because it hurt.
I mean, we're human
beings, right?
When somebody says,
hey, all the effort
that you're putting into
making this organization better
is not right.
You're not doing
it the right way.
I felt hurt.
I felt like, oh,
my gosh, this is
the only way I know how to
contribute and blah blah blah.
It was great that
my boss had my back.
And I also learned something
that was freaky and unexpected
which was that joy
is actually really
confrontational to people
who are not choosing
to live within a state of joy.
And that was both disheartening
and really powerful
information.
So, that's why I sort of
preach the good word of joy,
because it is a mindset
and it's something
we can choose, even in rigid,
rule-bound environments.
It's really the only
thing that we have.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So, how do you
deal with the perception,
if you've received this, that
when you switch projects,
that people might
think that you're
unreliable or
flighty or unfocused?
How do you deal with that?
TANIA KATAN: I wrote an
entire book all about that.
I'm being totally sincere.
So, for years people would
say, so what do you do?
And I was like, I am a curator
of everything-- whatever.
I just made stuff up until I
realized that if I assessed
my skills, my superpowers and
understood what those were,
then it opened up
everything-- that I could
go into any field, any job.
So, the clarity
comes in knowing what
you're bringing,
because you bring that
to whatever situation.
You bring that to
the supermarket.
your family parties.
You bring that to work.
So, the sooner I
understood what I brought,
the easier it was for me to
leap into different forms.
And that's something-- we
obviously live in a system
and a society
that's very siloed--
and we have business
cards to prove that.
You are a developer, you are--
and I remember, I
was at a conference--
I was speaking to 500 CIOs.
Any CIOs here?
Great.
Let the jokes rip.
So, I was in the
back of the room,
and there were 500 CIOs
all dressed in suits--
varying colors from
dark blue to black.
And it was a Saturday, so they
didn't have to wear suits.
So you know they were like this.
And I was in the back watching
the speaker before me,
and I was freaking out
because he was talking
about like AI and IA and VR.
And I'm like, unless they
want a monologue about TMI
or UTI or BMWs, I had nothing.
I was totally scared.
And, to make matters
worse, he's killing it.
And the CIOs are going wild.
They're like-- and I'm
like, ah, where's the exit?
And then the MC
grabs the microphone
and he's like, oh,
let's thank Steve.
And then we'd like to welcome
to the stage, Tania Katan,
she is a CIO.
And I'm like, oh, hell
no, I'm not a CIO.
Another self-limiting belief.
And I'm not a CIO.
And then he grabs the
mic and he's like--
chief inspiration officer.
And I was like, oh, my god.
So, what I learned from that--
what I learned
from that moment--
and I write about it because
it was so impactful--
is that I thought when people
ask you what do you do,
that it meant, what's
your job title?
But, in that moment, I
realized, oh, it's my purpose.
That's what I do.
And the more certain and
comfortable you are with that,
the more you can bring it in.
And when somebody
says, what do you do?
You can make up a job title.
You can tell them, here's
my purpose, or sit down,
I'm not going to give
you an elevator pitch.
If you really want
to know, let me
share what I do in the world.
So, great question, thank you.
AUDIENCE: So, for people who may
not consider themselves super
creative, are there
tools or strategies
that you advise to maybe
tap into creativity?
You mentioned with
your campaign,
you figured that out on a
walk or some kind of strategy
where maybe we step away
from our day to day,
not so creative work to
tap into the creative.
TANIA KATAN: Absolutely.
That's a great question.
So, first of all,
I would like to say
that creativity is defined as,
really, using your imagination.
It's not about making art
or painting or duh duh duh.
You could do that.
But creativity is about
using your imagination.
So, one thing that I recommend
in "Creative Trespassing"
is to ditch school.
Anybody ditch school as a kid?
Yeah.
We learned all
the skills we need
to disrupt our patterns
and habits that
are keeping us stuck.
So, what I recommend is that
you get up from your desk--
you don't have anything
to prove by working
until you're sweating and you're
regretting the job you took--
OK?
Nothing to prove.
Get up, take a five-minute,
10-minute walk.
Stanford did a study on walking
and the impact of creativity.
And it raises your
creativity by 60%.
So, when you find
yourself trapped
in trying to solve a problem
or just stuck in a routine,
get up and go for a walk.
And, in fact, there's something
called the Museum of Walking
that I'm a board member of.
And it's true.
And you'll look it up.
And, basically,
the museum exists
outside of the wall-- there
are no walls to the museum.
What?
Why don't you Google that later.
Oh, my god.
I was trying to weave that in.
Anyway.
And then throughout the
book, I have these things
called productive
disruptions, and they're
exercises because I know that
when we disrupt these holding
patterns, we
actually do more work
and have more joy in
that state of creating--
or co-creating work.
Yeah, thank you.
AUDIENCE: This
work is incredible,
and you are a
phenomenal speaker.
I'm sure you wake up
every morning with ideas,
but what's next for you?
You've written a book,
you're a public speaker.
TANIA KATAN: Oh, my gosh.
Gosh, this is where
I think my meditation
practice has messed me up.
What's next is what's now.
I don't know what else
to say about that.
What's next is me
continuing to speak.
So, a lot of companies bring
me in to give talks and teach
workshops on how do we use
creative skills for, maybe,
theater or contemporary
art to innovate
from within our companies.
I would like to be
doing more and more--
I could do that all day.
And I think a lot of
people ask, well, you
come from performance,
don't you want
to perform again on a stage?
And, to me, the
most impactful work
is being an outsider
on the inside.
And then you quickly realize
when you're like, hey,
you guys, I do wild things.
And they're like, I do too.
Oh, my god, there are creative
trespassers everywhere.
And, so, really, the end game
with "Creative Trespassing"
is to cause a creative
revolution inside our bodies,
our minds, and our cubicles.
That's all.
Thank you.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
With the theme of
International Women's Day
being "Balance for Better,"
can you talk about what balance
means for you?
TANIA KATAN: Oh.
Sleeping eight hours.
You know what?
So, as in my introduction,
you learned I actually
have gone through cancer two
times-- one when I was 21,
one was when I was 31 years old.
And when you've
endured an illness,
or if you're living
with an illness,
you are painfully aware
of the body and the mind
and the connection
or the moments
when one wants to
disconnect, because it's
painful and uncomfortable.
And, after enduring those
two bouts of cancer,
I realized I needed to
take care of myself.
So, even though I'm
sort of on book tour
and I'm going back and back,
how I care for myself is I
eat well.
And I'm open to dinners
being paid for by anyone.
Then I eat better.
I eat well.
I try to walk every day.
And I say, try, because
sometimes I'm limited in time.
But even then, I
literally will walk around
like a hotel parking lot.
My body feels better
when it's walked.
And also I meditate and
that makes me really--
that makes me consider
what's in front of me
rather than what's ahead of me.
And I think that's
really important,
because if I'm not occupying
this space right here and right
now, I actually don't know
what's going to be next.
I won't be open to what's
next and I want to be open.
So, yeah, that's it.
Great question.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: First of
all, great talk.
Thank you so much for
sharing your story with us.
I do feel like you have
the answers for everything.
But I wanted to know, did you
ever experience self-doubt
in each of your journeys?
And, if yes, how
did you combat that?
TANIA KATAN: Oh, yes.
All the time.
And, in fact, what just--
I'll go with the first thing
that popped into my head.
When I started my job
at the museum, I mean,
I don't have an art
history background,
I've never been a curator.
Like, I was the weirdest
choice for that job.
And so, I was freaking
out the day before
and I combated it by
saying, what do I wear?
How do I look arty?
How do I look like
I work in a museum?
Because my big,
self-limiting belief
since I was little until
now was, I don't fit in.
I don't belong here.
That has been a
refrain in the past.
So, I'm aware of that.
And so, what I do
is the same thing
I've learned in theater school--
you have to see an audience, you
have to listen to an audience,
you have to decide what you're
going to give to an audience.
And I don't mean this
in a performative way,
I mean this is like
an interpersonal way.
So I'm like, OK, they're
a contemporary art--
so I just sort of assessed
the situation and thought,
I will wear a blue shirt
and an orange blazer
and red glasses and
some funky sneakers.
Yes, I looked like
a cartoon character,
but it made me feel like I was
embodying the spirit of art.
So, that's what I do.
And, also, I was
recently telling
a story for "The Moth" in
front of 2,000 human beings.
And I hadn't done a
storytelling in that form,
and I was scared--
super scared.
So, here's what I did
in that situation.
I'm about to go on,
and I say to myself--
Tania, if you pass out,
you don't have to go on.
"Creative Trespassing."
And so, this is something I've
learned from one of my teachers
and from reading
and watching her--
Pema Chodron-- is that when
you are experiencing fear,
it's sort of the last
thing on our list
to do to like embrace it.
And she's like, go into it.
Barrel headfirst into fear.
And then you realize,
oh, it's not so bad.
I came out on the other side.
We always come out
on the other side.
You know that, and that's why
the leap of faith is important.
The middle part,
you're like, ah.
But you always know that
you're going to land, right?
And that it's going
to be more than OK.
So, that's what I do.
AUDIENCE: Hey.
So, it's really cool to hear
about how confident you are
and your purpose and what
you bring to the table.
And you've talked about
how it's important to be
grounded in that.
How do you get to
that point, though?
If you could talk to that.
TANIA KATAN: Yeah, that's
an awesome question.
So, first of all, the way in
which we write books, the way
in which we live lives--
all of it is a practice.
I approach it as a practice.
I'm not the only one.
There's a practice of
meditation-- doctors practice
medicine.
Those who play
instruments practice.
So, when we think about
it as a practice--
and if it's a
practice, guess what?
It's never going to
be perfect, right?
It's a practice.
So, if we think of
building skills around,
I want to be more
curious, I want
to be more confident--
as practicing,
I'm going to try on what
confident looks like or feels
like to me today.
OK, that didn't work.
That's OK, but one
moment within that,
I did feel a little confident.
Then you remember-- then you
try it again the next day,
and then the next day.
And then what happens is
something I learned in theater
which is muscle memory--
guess what?
Your body knows what to do.
It shows up without your
mind messing things up.
So, you have to
practice embodying
what it is you
want to be and how
you want to be in the world
every day a little bit.
Is that helpful?
I think we're going to
take two more questions.
AUDIENCE: How did you
come to find your purpose?
And what tools did
you use and which
ones did you like most of all?
TANIA KATAN: So, I've written
about this, because it's
taken me lots of tools.
And, in "Creative Trespassing,"
an exercise that I have is
it's called, write
your fight song.
But, really, it's a manifesto.
Who here knows what
a manifesto is?
Yeah, it's a powerful
declaration of your purpose--
of your why and your how.
Like, yes, I declare
this, and here's
how I'm going to actually
do something about it.
So, it's not
passive, it's active.
And so, I've found my--
I say, purpi, because I don't
think we have one purpose.
And I think that this is also
one of those system silo traps
we find ourselves in.
And I've definitely
found myself in it.
I majored in theater, how come
I can't get a job in theater?
I have no purpose--
and scene.
I'm using my degree.
And I've often found
myself in that trap,
and then I realize, oh,
wait, my purpose is--
and another indicator is,
what really enlivens you when
you're in the act of doing it?
So, if you are coding and
you're like, holy shit,
this is so awesome, this
feels good and every fiber--
or you're a problem
solver, you're a presenter
and you're like, I like people.
I like when they ask questions.
Those are all indicators
of your purpose.
So, I guess, buy the
book and do the exercise?
And also-- and also, just
know that you monitor--
you're the conductor of
the experiment of you,
and so you can be
aware of situations
where you feel like this
makes me feel alive,
and it enlivens those around me.
Maybe this is one
of my purposes.
Great question.
Thank you.
OK, we had a super quick--
we had a creative trespasser
question.
Didn't need a
microphone-- love that.
How often do I burst into song?
Like in my daily life?
Oh, well, I am known far and
wide as the monotone wonder.
So, I don't typically--
but I burst into song always
when I'm on a road trip
by myself.
And I'm like, oh-ahh--
because I hit all
the right notes when
it's just an audience of me.
But I dance all the time.
So like in supermarkets
and conferences and things
like that-- just,
inadvertently even sometimes.
I'm like what?
That's awesome.
Thanks for asking.
AUDIENCE: I was
totally rooting for you
with your Employee
of the Month video.
And I was curious
if you actually
won Employee of the Month.
TANIA KATAN: Beautiful, Yeah.
OK, so, again, my intention
with doing these videos
was to actually get
to know my colleagues,
engage them in a playful
manner, and check things
off the boxes of my job.
And what happened
was-- and, you know,
I received that feedback
of, you're not a good hire,
Tania Katan, get rid of her.
I got an email-- and do you ever
get that ominous email that's--
everyone-- all employees,
meet in the boardroom.
I received an email
from HR that was that
and I was like, oh, my god.
And so, I kind of
like slowly walked in.
I walked in the
room everybody was
seated there and very stiff.
And, all of a sudden,
the head of HR said,
Tania, we'd like to
present you with something.
And a video camera comes
up and they present me
with this big plaque that says,
Almost Employee of the Month.
And, to me, that's
the best metric
for succeeding is that not
only are they connecting,
but they're also engaging
in play and creativity.
So, that was a really
wonderful moment.
Thank you for asking.
Yeah.
Well, thank you so
much for having me.
I appreciate it.
[APPLAUSE]